the mudslide hit before dawn
and for the families asleep in these
homes in eastern uganda's kisses
district there was nothing they could do
[Music]
we strive to see to clear that much to
see if we can retrieve more bodies they
are saying those houses were
overpopulated and only two people
survived
most of those killed were women and
children
cases which lies near the congolese
border is prone to deadly landslides
this time of year and forecasters had
warned of unusually strong and
destructive rains
so as we continue receiving more
abnormal heavy rainfall in the area it's
likely that even the river might burst
its banks and so we're already
conducting a early warning to the
members of the community who live around
the same river and around the river
banks
after a long drought the heavy rains
have fallen since late july
triggering floods and mudslides across
the country and leaving hundreds of
people homeless
uganda's government has previously
blamed climate change but these steep
hillsides are also becoming more
vulnerable to landslides because of
deforestation over population or
terracing for farming
the damage is so great and the actual as
people cases we appealing to government
of uganda and well-wishers the donors
come to our rescue because our people
have nowhere to stay now
the rainy season is set to continue
until december authorities are advising
people living in mountainous regions to
be vigilant or move to safer areas this
community though is preparing to bury
the dead
alexia o'brien al jazeera